ils ont dit ce qu'il faudrait ils m'ont
montré que c'était moi et donc après
j'ai senti qu'on me pousser et on m'a
poussé dans l'escalier
la violence ça reste il est en son
qu'est-ce qu'il a eu comme il a eu la
paupière du baouvert et une fracture du
nez
vous allez forcément en direct avec
l'école vous a appelé non trouver dans
quel état
partout et dès qu'il m'a vu je me
rappelle s'écrit maman et en fait il a
eu un relâchement et là il a tout vidé
il s'est mis à pleurer
à midi pour récupérer mon fils et il y a
un feu rouge devant le collège et je
m'arrête au feu rouge et je vois mon
fils qui se fait tringler par un autre
enfant et il touche tout le sol il est
sourire comme ça
il m'a dit je m'amuse c'est pas
amusement ça le directeur
d'établissement il vous a dit voilà
votre fils s'est fait pousser dans les
escaliers merci madame de venir comment
on fait pour le virer du lycée et du
collège
comment on fait